a few years ago I set out on a mission
to find God now I'm gonna tell you right
up front that I failed which as a lawyer
is a really hard thing for me to admit
but on that failed journey a lot of what
I found was enlightening and one thing
in particular gave me a lot of hope and
it has to do with the magnitude and
significance of our differences so I was
raised in America by Indian parents
culturally Hindu but practicing a strict
and relatively unknown religion outside
of India called Jennison
to give you an idea of just how minority
that makes me people from India
represent roughly 1% of the US
population
Hindus about 0.7% Jones at most point
zero zero zero four six percent to put
that in context more people visit the
Vermont teddy bear factory each year
than our followers the John religion in
America to add to my minority mix my
parents undecided what a great idea
let's send her to Catholic school where
my sister and I were the only non-white
non Catholic students in the entire
school at the infant Jesus or Prague
school and floss more Illinois yes
that's really what it was called we were
taught to believe that there is a single
Supreme Being who is responsible for
everything the whole shebang from
creation of the universe to moral
shepherding to eternal life but at home
I was being taught something entirely
different
followers of the China religion don't
believe in a single Supreme Being or
even a team of supreme beings instead
we're taught that God manifests as a
perfection of each of us as individuals
and that we're actually spending our
entire lives striving to remove the bad
Karma's that stand in the way of us
becoming our own godlike perfect cells
on top of that one of the core principle
of Jainism is something called non
absolutism non absolutist believed that
no single person can hold ownership or
knowledge of absolute truth even when it
comes to religious beliefs the blood
testing that concept out on the priests
and nuns in your Catholic school no
wonder I was confused and hyper aware of
how different I was from my peers cut to
twenty-something years later and I found
myself to be a highly spiritual person
but I was floundering I was spiritually
homeless I came to learn that I was a
nun which isn't an acronym or clever
play on words nor is it one of these
it's simply the painfully uninspired
name given to everyone who checks off
the box nun when pew research ask them
about their religious affiliation now a
couple of interesting things about nuns
are there are a lot of us and we skew
young in 2014 there were over 56 million
religiously unaffiliated nuns in the
United States and nuns account for over
one-third of adults between the ages of
18 to 33 but the most interesting thing
to me about nuns is that were often
spiritual in fact 68% of us believe with
some degree of certainty that there is a
God we're just not sure who it is so the
first take away from me when I realized
that I was nun and had found that
information out was that I wasn't alone
I was finally part of a group in America
that had a lot of members which felt
really reassuring but on the second not
so reassuring takeaway was that oh man
there are a lot of us that can't be good
because of a lot of highly spiritual
people are currently godless maybe
finding God's not gonna be as easy as I
had originally hoped so bad is when I
decided that on my spiritual journey I
was going to avoid the obvious places
and skip the big box religions
altogether and instead venture out into
the spiritual fringe of mediums and
faith healer
and God Menton but remember I'm an on
absurdist which means I was pretty
inclined to keep a fairly open mind
which turned out to be a good thing
because I went to a witches potluck
dinner at the LGBT Center in New York
City where I befriended two witches
drank a five-gallon jerrican full of
volcanic water with a shaman in Peru got
a hug from a saint in the Convention
Center she smelled really nice chanted
for hours in a smoke-filled heat infused
sweat lodge on the beaches of Mexico
worked with the tequila drinking medium
to convene with the dead who oddly
included both my deceased mother-in-law
and the deceased manager of a hip hop
group the roots and my mother-in-law
told me she was really happy her son had
chosen me for his wife da but yeah the
manager of the roots said that maybe I
should cut back on all the pasta I was
eating I think we can all agree it was
lucky for my husband that it wasn't his
dead mother who suggested by way of
carbs I also joined a laughing yoga
group out of South Africa witnessed a
woman have a 45-minute orgasm I am NOT
making this up as she tapped into the
energy of the universe I think I'm gonna
go back there called God from a phone
booth in the Nevada desert at Burning
Man wearing a unit heart in ski goggles
and I had an old Indian guy lie on top
of me and no he wasn't my husband this
was a perfect stranger named param ji
and he was chanting into my chakras as
he tapped into the energy forces of the
universe to heal my yoni which is a
Sanskrit word for a vagina I was going
to have a slide here but a few people
suggested that a slide of my yoni at Ted
even Ted women not the best idea
very early in my quest I also went to
see the Brazilian faith healer John of
God at his compound down in Brazil now
John of God is considered a full trance
medium which basically means he can talk
to dead people but in his case he claims
to channel a very specific group of dead
Saints and doctors in order to heal
whatever's wrong with you and although
John of God does not have a medical
degree or even a high school diploma he
actually performs surgery
they're real kind with a scalpel but no
anesthesia yeah he also offers invisible
surgery where there is no cutting and
surrogate surgery where he supposedly
can treat somebody who is thousands of
miles away by performing a procedure on
a loved one now when you go to visit
John there God through all kinds of
rules and regulations it's a whole
complicated thing but the bottom line is
that you can visit John of God and
present him with three things that you
would like fixed and he will set the
dead seats and doctors to work on your
behalf to get the job done now before
you snicker consider that at least
according to his website over 8 million
people including Oprah the goddess of
daytime TV have gone to see John of God
and I was pre-wired to keep an open mind
let's be honest the whole thing for me
it was kind of weird and inconclusive
and in the end I flew home even more
confused when I already started out but
that doesn't mean I came home
empty-handed in the weeks leading up to
my trip to Brazil I mentioned my
upcoming plans to some friends and to a
couple of colleagues at Google where I
was a lawyer at the time and I might
have mentioned it a couple more people
because I'm chatty including my neighbor
guy who works at the local coffee shop I
go to each morning the checkout lady to
Whole Foods and a stranger who sat next
to me on the subway
I told each of them where I was going
and why and I offered to carry three
wishes of theirs down to Brazil
explaining that anyone going to see John
of God could act as a proxy for other
and save them the trip and she might
surprise my inbox overflowed friends
told friends you told friends and those
friends apparently told more friends and
other strangers and the guys at their
coffee shops until it seemed that days
before I left for Brazil but there was
no one who did not have my email address
and at the time all I could conclude was
that I had offered too much to too many
but one I actually reread those messages
a few years later I noticed something
completely different those emails
actually shared three commonalities the
first of which was rather curious
almost everyone sent me meticulous
details about how they could be reached
so I had told them where their friends
had told them but along with the list of
the three things they wanted fixed I
needed their photo their name and their
date of birth but they gave me full
addresses like apartment numbers and zip
codes as if John of God doesn't stop by
their house and see them in person or
send along a package it was as if in the
highly unlikely event that their wishes
were granted by John of God they just
wanted to make sure that they weren't
delivered to the wrong person or the
wrong address even if they didn't
believe they were hedging their bets the
second commonality was just as curious
but far more humbling virtually everyone
the stranger on the subway the guy of a
coffee shop the lawyer down the hall the
Jew the atheist the Muslim the devout
Catholic all asked for essentially the
same three things okay there were a
couple of outliers and yes a few people
asked for cash but when I eliminated
what were ultimately a handful of
anomalies the similarities were
staggering almost every single person
first asked for good health for
themselves and their families almost
universally the next ask for happiness
and then love in that order health
happiness love sometimes they asked for
a specific health issue to be fixed but
more often than not they just asked for
good health in general when it came to
happiness
they each phrased it slightly
differently but they all asked for the
same specific subtype of happiness - the
kind of happiness that sinks in and sets
down roots in your soul the kind of
happiness that could sustain us even if
we were to lose absolutely everything
else and for love they all asked for the
kind of romantic love the soulmate that
we read about an epic romantic novels
the kind of love that will stay with us
till the end of our days sorry that's my
husband
crap now I forgot my place
[Applause]
so by and large all of these friends and
strangers regardless of their background
race or religion all asked for the same
things and they were the same things
that I really wanted a simplified
version of the basic human needs
identified by social scientists like
Abraham Maslow and Manfred max-neef no
one asked for answers to the big
existential questions or for proof of
God or the meaning of life like I had
set out to find they didn't even ask for
an end to war global hunger even when
they could have asked for absolutely
anything they all asked for health
happiness and love so now those emails
had a third commonality as well each of
them ended in the exact same way instead
of thanking me for carting their wishes
all the way to Brazil
everyone said please don't tell anyone
so I decided to tell everyone right here
on this stage
not because I'm untrustworthy
but because the fact that we have so
much in common
feels especially important for us all to
hear especially now when so many of the
world's problems seem to be because we
keep focusing on the things that make us
different not on what binds us together
and look I am the first to admit that I
am NOT a statistician and that the data
I presented to you that I just
accumulated in my inbox is more
anecdotal than scientific more
qualitative and quantitative it is as
anyone who works with data would tell
you hardly a statistically significant
or demographically balanced sample but
nonetheless I find myself thinking about
those emails every time I reflect back
on the bias and Prejudice that I've
faced in my life or when there is
another hate crime or a senseless
tragedy that underscores the
disheartening sense that our differences
might be insurmountable I then remind
myself that I have evidence at the
unifying commonality of our humanity is
that even when presented with the
opportunity to ask for anything at all
most of us want the same things and that
this is true no matter who we are what
name we call our God or which religion
if any we call home I then also note
that apparently some of us want these
things so badly that we would email a
nun a spiritually confused none like me
some might say otherwise confused as
well but and that we would seek out this
stranger and email her our deepest
wishes just in case there is the remote
possibility that they might be granted
by someone who is not a god must much
less our God someone who is not even a
member of our chosen religion someone
who when you look at it on paper seems
like an unlikely candidate to deliver
and so now when I reflect back on my
spiritual quest even though I did not
find God I found a home in this even
today in a world fractured by religious
ethnic political philosophical and
racial divides even with all of our
obvious differences at the end of the
day than the most fundamental level we
are all the same
[Applause]